I have done less work on this one and I
have the others have a look and I'll
tell you why I factorized you can see
answer any factor I three this one yes
good thank you very much so you can see
I've got two of the factors drawn but
I've elected not to draw to the other
factors here's one you got X plus 21x on
there right then you've got X minus
three and you've got it happening twice
so if I were to draw it I guess it would
look something like this there's one of
them and there's the other one right on
top now remember why I'm drawing these
back to life I'm trying them to
understand something about the sign the
regions that my actual thing has to go
through right well have a look at these
guys how much do they contribute to the
sign what the moment both member
negative so what's the result positive
what about here they're both positive
still positive so therefore they
contribute nothing better change the
sign at all another way you can think
about it this is that factor lines I
said nothing about the fact Alliance
always having to be straight what does y
equals x minus 3 all squared what does
it look like it's a parabola that looks
like this it's always positive except
for that spot right there okay when the
whole function doesn't exist anyway
because you've got a denominator 0 so
that's why I have not drawn it so these
two factor lines that I've got books
sorry these two facts might sound like
here that's all I need
let's quickly go through a chain two
negatives will give you a positive a
positive or negative here and then the
rest of it is positive do you agree yeah
and there's a horizontal asymptote this
is an easy one what is it 2-0 I don't
need to hover that's just zero so let's
go ahead and draw that across I don't
know intercepts yet can someone tell me
what the Interceptor
negative what is a number tell me an
intercept x equals negative 1 so that's
that guy there and nothing else because
there's a vertical asymptote on the
y-axis ok so that's it
that's that's all my rules so what am I
going to do well you can see I've got to
come down here to this asymptote right
I've got this asymptote to approach but
I have to be in this positive region so
what am I gonna do I'm gonna have to
come up and then back down again so
something like that
what about here is that a section right
yeah this is the the not parabola right
I'm going to call it a drop problem
because it's not a parabola like that
and then what about on the right hand
side it's it's like a hyperbola they go
and there's the shape